[Music]
no regrets Wendy Williams is opening up
about her struggle with addiction I am
NOT embarrassed you know about anything
et sat down exclusively with the 54 year
old talk-show host as she launched the
inaugural Wendy Williams and the hunter
Foundation's be here campaign to combat
drug addiction and the substance abuse
crisis Wendy got extremely candid about
her own struggles
I was the functioning addict my before
it to work on time and I walk in and all
of my co-workers including my bosses
would know but instead of firing me you
say I would grab my headphones and
arrogantly walk in the studio and didn't
fire me because I was making ratings a
functioning addict has several alarm
clocks you're organized in February 2018
Wendy announced she would be taking a
three-week hiatus from her successful
talk show due to her battle with
hyperthyroidism and Graves disease just
months after fainting on live television
for more on Wendy's health tune in to ET
Thursday July 19
[Music]
you
[Music]